nuestra corresponsal en teherán catalina
gómez ángel nos habló de como este
anuncio no hace desaparecer la
incertidumbre lo que crea más
expectativas e incertidumbre de si esto
podrá llegar a ser una realidad porque a
otros países que hacen es en parte de
ese acuerdo nuclear especialmente
francia ha pedido que si se vuelve a
esta mesa también se negocie el por el
programa de misiles iraní a lo que irán
siempre se ha negado esto se suma que ha
cambiado el equipo negociador iraní es
un equipo mucho más radical que el que
existía antes no tiene tanto
conocimiento de estos documentos que se
habían firmado en el 2015 lo que se
venía sucediendo ya hace meses en viana
así que crecen las expectativas y es la
incertidumbre y hay gente muchos a quien
irán que son negativos frente a esta
posibilidad de volver a viena